yeah well i mean the the gender issue is
really an interesting one because
one of my professional domains of
expertise is individual differences i'm
i'm a personality psychologist and so
i know the gender difference literature
and it's
it's a very solid literature well first
of all it's very solid
it has a 30-year history once per
psychologist got the personality models
down so that would be the big five model
all empirically derived straight
statistics right brute force empiricism
nobody had a theoretical axe to grind
with the big five except to say
maybe there are human traits maybe
they're encapsulated in language
we can use statistical techniques to
find out what they are that was it
that's the whole
ideology so very very neutral as far as
ideologies go
five traits emerge okay
are there differences between the sexes
turns out there are
all right they're not massive although
if you sum them across all the traits
you can separate men and women with
about 75
accuracy so it's not trivial but you
have to sum across all the traits
then another question comes up well are
those differences sociocultural
or biological okay we can test that
we'll go around the world
we'll look at cultures we'll rank order
them in terms of the
gender equality of their sociological
policies
we can do that with broad agreement from
the right and the left
then the hypothesis would be if gender
differences decrease
among more egalitarian societies then
the gender differences are sociocultural
or at least more sociocultural
that's exactly the opposite of what was
found
repeatedly that's pseudoscience it's
like no
that's mainstream psychology those
papers have thousands of citations and
right
the average humanities paper has zero
citations right and then the next most
common one has one
three thousand that's an that's an
unbelievable classic
and and here's the other bit of proof
like you say well how do you know
that you can trust someone's judgment
about a fact
the fact emerges despite their
ideological presuppositions
okay so it's well known that the social
sciences
and the humanities have a have a left
tilt
and a lot of that's temperamental and
the tilt has become more pronounced
but as jonathan heidis pointed out there
are no conservatives among social
personality or or or none to speak
very few vanishingly few and if the
field has a bias it is
definitely and indisputably a left-wing
bias
okay so you have to fight that if you're
if you're a scientist right even if
you're a left-wing scientist you have to
fight that because you want to get to
the facts
it was these social scientists who
generated the data that suggested that
the gender differences not only were
real but that were bigger in egalitarian
societies
they didn't do that to grind their
ideological acts because their
ideological presupposition was
no no you make the society egalitarian
men and women get more the same it's
like
nope they get more different oh hmm
isn't that something and so then there's
a corollary there which is
all right you could still say and
they're kind of pushing in this
direction in scandinavia
boys and girls are different men and
women are different
it looks biological but because people
are malleable
you could push the sociocultural
structure harder and harder
to minimize the biological differences
okay well first of all
maybe and maybe not maybe you'd get a
rebound and they'd get even
like the kids would rebel that could
easily happen but let's say okay you
could
the problem with that is is that if you
seed that much
power to the state like you're basically
giving the state the right to socialize
your kids
right it's like you you really
really you really want to do that i mean
the people in israel couldn't do that
with the cabooses
right it didn't work so people aren't
going to give up their children to the
state and thank god for that well i mean
this is one of the big questions that we
were discussing earlier is that we were
talking about
the polarization and politics between
right and left and obviously
you're you're a psychologist you're a
philosopher
but you've been dragged almost kicking
and screaming into this political sphere
because everything has been
so politicized and so when you say when
you cite social science
statistics and they're scientifically
based you're called a racist you're
called the sexist you're called the
homophobe
and you're called exactly so so why is
it that
so why do you think it is that so many
folks on the left who purport to be all
about
reason and science and and objective
fact are so willing to
throw those out the window uh the minute
that it becomes politically inconvenient
well because imagine that cognitive
systems
or an interpretation of the world has
levels they're axiomatic levels some
fundamental presuppositions are more
fundamental than others
and you could say well the leftists
historically maybe because of their
atheistic rationality
are more on the side of science than say
the fundamentalists
of of any sort but when push comes to
shove
you find out how the axioms are are
nested
there's deeper axioms underneath that
which is that
all hierarchies are based on power and
all power plays are based on group
identity tribal identity essentially
and that the entire history of the world
is nothing but a power play between
between these different identity groups
it's like okay well if the science
indicates that some of that's wrong then
do you alter
those beliefs or do you alter the
science and the answer to that question
is well it depends on how you've
hierarchically arranged those
if the science is at the bottom then you
alter your beliefs
right if the scientific facts are the
axiomatic
substructure then you then you alter
your beliefs if your beliefs are the
axiomatic substructure
then you alter the science well we've
seen how that plays out
and one of the things i've tried to do
so to speak is to diagnose the axiomatic
structure
it's like okay what's the what's the
metaphysical
presumption structure of the radical
left well
what it is is you're basically your
group
your groups are basically engaged in
warfare
right and the warfare is arbitrary
except in so far as it serves
your group okay i don't buy any of that
i think that's
i think that's a route to certain
disaster i think it's a degeneration
into tribalism
and that we will seriously pay for it
not only because it returns us to
tribalism and tribes fight
as the anthropological evidence for that
is overwhelming
right tribes fight it doesn't even
matter if they're chimpanzee tribes
even chimpanzee tribes fight so
not only do you re regress to a
tribalism
but you also invalidate the one
proposition that's
been able to help us arise above the
tribal which is the idea
that the individual should be sovereign
and so i think the culture war
is about what's the proper framework
within which to view
human identity and what's the
relationship between the individual and
the group
in relationship to that identity and the
leftist answer is
it's all group and it's all power it's
like okay
did you know that every like on this
video creates one additional
glorious leftist here don't ask me why
that's called science
to take advantage of this amazing
opportunity just hit the like button